Speaker 1: Let's go to our friend Bitdefender
from Cancun, Mexico.
This is not Eric from Cancun.
This is a different Cancun caller who goes
by Bitdefender Bit.
You're on.
Speaker 5: Hello, David.
Hello.
Be well, I wanted to talk about something
that happened in Mexico that I think some
Americans ought to know just in case something
similar happens in the states.
OK, so the 10th of April, we had a special
election of sorts and assumed the role of
assuming the mandate, but which is essentially
an election where you go to vote to get rid
of the president?
Speaker 1: Is it almost like it's almost like
a no confidence vote of the of the people,
right?
Speaker 5: Exactly.
Yeah, now it sounds sort of democratic, but
the reality of it is that it's something that
mostly exists in autocratic countries and
countries that, well, leaders that want to
campaign constantly.
You know what I mean?
Yes, especially in countries that pretend
or have democratic democratic systems that
you know, have electoral law of sorts.
But you very well know that the elections
are not fair and free.
Sure.
You know, Venezuela, Ecuador, some other Latin
American countries have this forum, and now
Mexico has it.
Given the rise of these forms of, you know,
government and governors, do you think we
will see something similar in the states?
Speaker 1: I don't think so.
I think it would be how presidential elections
run, at least in theory, is so set in stone
that I don't believe that there's going to
be the putting in the in statement of such
a mechanism.
And also, you know, as you point out, one
of the ideas of the propaganda value of it
is that you can kind of constantly be running
an election and that can sometimes help to
coalesce and organize people.
The Republican Party has already figured out
how to do the same thing by by saying Democrats
are going to try to steal it, which is what
they did in 2020.
And so they already kind of have a mechanism
to make that rallying cry.
So no, I don't expect that to be instated
in the United States.
Speaker 5: Also another you mention it, you
know, given the nature of electoral law in
you're in the states, what gives you so much
confidence that, you know, electoral law is
so set in stone?
You know me coming from a country where we
have an actual federal institute dedicated
to electoral management and the states don't
really have one.
You know,
Speaker 1: I mean, maybe I'm naive to think
that, but the only real sense I have is that
if anything was going to structurally change
the way elections are done, it would be something
like the national popular vote Interstate
Compact, where states can decide, Oh yeah,
we'll just give our electors to the winner
of the popular vote.
But beyond that, there's not really any serious
initiatives there.
I mean, they're they're trying to steal it
by not officially changing the big picture,
but by doing voter suppression at the state
level, strategic voter ID, closing polling
places.
They're looking to do it piecemeal rather
than with any big mechanism like a public,
no confidence voter that Typekit.
It's just what they're doing.
And so I'm basing it on what
I see.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
That's
a very thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you.
There's a bit defender from Cancun.